se mantiene además sigue creciendo la
cifra de contagios a pesar de que el
número de muertos pues ha reducido
significativamente la gente está en la
calle en los restaurantes como vemos
atrás en los bares ha salido a hacer
deporte montar en bicicleta ya sin
máscaras se ven estas personas pues
haciendo deporte en las calles de la
ciudad y es que entre las
recomendaciones precisamente está que
las personas que ya tengan las dos
vacunas las dos dosis y hayan esperado
esperado ya dos semanas pueden salir
precisamente hacer deporte pueden salir
a reunirse con sus amigos en bares en
restaurantes al área al aire libre
incluso pueden reunirse con sus
familiares y grupos cercanos en espacio
cerrado el presidente de bailén lo
decías no pueden sin embargo o tienen
que seguir portando las máscaras en
estadios en conciertos y en agro
operaciones grandes es de resaltar que
pues cerca del 42 por ciento de los
estadounidenses ya tienen al menos con
una vacuna a cerca del 30 por ciento ya
tienen las dos vacunas así que se siente
entonces el ambiente
si fuera el primer paso para regresar a
la normalidad acá en la ciudad vemos
mucha actividad detrás de usted de
cristóbal incluso pasaron o un par de
personas ya sin mascarilla y vemos la
actividad comercial un poco más viva ya
según las imágenes que nos llegan qué
efecto puede tener esto entonces en la
economía del país cuáles han sido las
reacciones por parte de los comerciantes
exactamente los comerciantes además que
hicieron mucho énfasis en tratar de
reabrir el comercio sobre todos los
restaurantes que durante este año largo
de pandemia han sido los más afectados
pues empujaron precisamente para poder
que las personas o los consumidores
pudieran volver a las mesas pudieran
volver a empezar a consumir y reactivar
la industria de los restaurantes que ha
sido una de las más golpeadas de hecho
no solamente en este restaurante detrás
mío sino en muchos de la ciudad se ven
los avisos ya siendo solicitando a
personas para que vengan a trabajar
nuevamente a los restaurantes así que se
empieza a sentir este ambiente de
dinamismo y de reactivación en esta área
además lo que están diciendo muchos
políticos y científicos es que
precisamente relajar un poco estas
medidas con las máscaras va a hacer que
las personas pues decidan las que están
todavía indecisas decidan ponerse la
vacuna para así entonces evitar ponerse
las máscaras entonces es un gana-gana de
alguna manera logra aumentar el
porcentaje de personas que pues todavía
no se ha decidido en vacunarse vacuna
al mismo tiempo pues reactiva la
economía oportuna de la medida sobre
todo de cara al verano que está por
llegar allí en el hemisferio norte y la
gente puede hacer más actividades al
aire libre muchas gracias cristóbal por
este informe